from calorie count to portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between cafes in japan and the u.s
this is food wars
so the fries at the cafes in japan come
in three sizes so this is small
and
next one is back again
then we've got
a box
now let's weigh our largest fries
[Laughter]
i'm shook as the kids say by that
information i want to say though that
theirs is like a box that thing is like
made to be eaten by more than one person
i'm assuming but this clearly this is
for a person so in japan we have three
drink sizes so we have a small
in the u.s our drinks come in a medium
and we got a large large
so in japan cafe doesn't disclose how
much liquid is in each of the sizes why
so i will help you kelsey we will
measure the cups right now let's go
so now let's measure our large and just
to make sure it's accurate we didn't
clean the measuring cup
go home
so at the cafes in japan you can order
your chicken pieces in
one piece two pieces three
pieces
four pieces
and six pieces
and eight pieces
and ten pieces
and
twelve pieces
kfc in the u.s our chicken portion sizes
start as a two-piece combo by the way
come on guys this isn't whatever
whatever this is supposed to be then the
three piece right in front of me here
that's the exact opposite i went extra
crispy for this look at the size of
these chicken pieces yes
yes to these and the four piece this is
somewhere in the middle and each combo
comes with a biscuit your choice of
potato either fries or mashed with gravy
and all of them come with a medium drink
but we don't stop there we go now to
buckets where you can get an 8-piece
bucket
12-piece bucket or 16-piece bucket
so now we are going to weigh our 8-piece
chicken to compare the weights in each
country
yo
it's pretty close considering all the
variables of
size of chicken
bone density
batter
i don't know what i'm talking about but
that's surprisingly close so in japan a
two piece of original chicken which are
breast and wing and small fries and a
medium drink cost 800 yen or
7.27 so japan actually kfc is considered
a little bit more expensive compared to
other fast food chains like mcdonald's
so it's a classic fast food in japan
that same meal is about
8.99 or in japanese yen
992.27 so that's about a 24 cost
increase in the us in japan to make
chicken at kfc you must be certified as
a chicken specialist and certification
takes three months and your knowledge
and skills are tested every year alright
so let's take chicken specialist test
right now right george let's do this
number one for the original chicken 100
percent domestic that's kind of a bummer
yeah
animal fertilizer fried with a lighter
weight without lighter weights and these
guys these got hard fast
i'm in over my head on this one i don't
even know what that means all right so
just now i've got all of the five
answers so let's check the answers gold
chicken circulation
gold
[Applause]
it says not kfc material it's a picture
of uh colonel sanders giving me the
finger so i'm gonna assume i did not
pass it but anyway i've got a goal
i'm the champion
i am very surprised by that i think i
could work for kfc i mean
i kind of look like colonel sanders
right look at this guy
i'm a younger colonel sanders kfc is
doing any sort of the adventures of
young colonel sanders ad campaign
is this a face they can sell chicken
yeah haven't you guys ever read the
secret i'm putting the energy that i
want out into the universe and it comes
back to me
and it's called manifesting
so here is everything you can only find
on the menu at the cafs in japan but not
in the u.s and here is everything you
can find and the menu in a us kfc you
cannot get in japan here we've got
cafe
both places have biscuits but their
biscuit has a hole in it it looks a lot
fluffier right our biscuit on the other
hand is just this southern style not
exactly a scone but kind of looks like
one from a distance dry cornmeal biscuit
it comes with honey maple cafe
oh
this is good the maple is a little bit
sweet for me mac and cheese i can't
believe you guys do not have macaroni
and cheese love mac and cheese mashed
potatoes and gravy you don't have that
in japan guys guys demand this from your
japanese kfc you want the mashed
potatoes and gravy so we also have
deep packs
it's got kernel crispy
um some nuggets
and boneless kentucky and some original
chicken so this deep pack it comes with
this price and also
these three
dipping sauces and now for the quickest
sauce talk ever
kfc sauce
i mean the casey sauce is like a brown
mustard mayo yeah that sauce is good so
we've got
barbecue sauce and
mustard and this pink one is called men
taiko mayo mentai comments is like spicy
kodu roll and very popular taste in
japan
this is actually great i'll dip this
it tastes fantastic winner
so if you want to have a little bigger
one you can order deep barrel i mean
it's double amount of this deep pack so
it's going to be very big so this one
right here is called four piece red hot
chicken box and it comes with a pie
and fry
and a medium drink and actually we have
other box options like four piece half
hot and half original box and it comes
with fries as well and
six piece half hot and half original box
it comes with fries again
so in japan we have torino pack that
means chicken day it's on every 28th of
the month and 2 stands for knee and 8
stands for
and it becomes niwa and niwa is
synonymous with niwa tori newa 3 means
chicken
so that's why it's called chicken day
kfc in america has extra crispy chicken
this is the best type of chick i mean
look at this i don't know what they do
to this but the skin is practically
falling off is so crispy and so
delicious i love extra crispy so much i
got this little guy
the chicken little look at this guy huh
there's a little guy comes with pickles
mayo
the pot pie that they have here they're
not kidding when they say pie in the pot
pie how thick this is speaking of big
dishes of stuff the famous bowl
once upon a time a kfc employee was like
how could i put everything into one dish
and call it a day and ta-da the famous
bowl was born this has to be like three
pounds all right so here we've got
two special twisters so this one right
here is called
pepper mayonnaise twister
[Music]
it looks great
nine out of ten kfc
thank you thank you for making me happy
so next we got ooh
teriyaki twister
should be great it's kind of gross
it's got mayo and colonel crispy some
veggies and i hope this is teriyaki
sauce
it looks gross but it tastes
incredible 10 out of 10. congratulations
oishii it means delicious look how tiny
those twisters are i could eat like
three of those easily easily all right
so we have
nuggets we have
three pieces
five pieces and they come with only
ketchup also the us kfc that you can't
get in japan are wings you can get wings
at the kfc and units of 6 12 24 or 48. i
believe the three wing flavors that i
got here are standard buffalo the
honey barbecue
and if you're a total wuss
on sauce what's wrong with you yeah very
sketchy you can also get them in a
limited time nashville hot sauce now we
have special sandwiches this one right
here is called japanese style chicken
cut sandwich so let's take a look inside
it's got mayo and it's got cabbage and
chicken cuts right there
oh
this sauce is like soy sauce based sauce
and it's a little bit sweet and this
mayo is also great with the sauce this
looks really small but
it has huge amount of chicken so if you
eat this you're gonna be full
and next one
we've got chicken fillet wow this is
also huge all right so this one right
here is called black hot sandwich
look at this it's like pepper mayo i
just tasted this paper mayo but it has a
little like spiciness oh
oh
man it's too strong i wouldn't get it be
careful now of course the u.s has a
chicken sandwich but our chicken
sandwich and their chicken sandwich as
you can see is way different you can
also get it spicy or classic this is
classic all right so this one right here
it's called coronal crispy is it only in
japan i cannot confirm the difference
between a kernel crispy and a kfc
chicken tender they call their tenders
colonel krispies and we call our colonel
crispies chicken tenders
it's been a while since i ordered this
one
but it still has
crispy bits
good job japanese chefs is technology
state of the art we currently have a
nashville hot chicken and hot tenders i
went ahead with the tenders i've just
been informed this was a big tic tac
thing for a minute something about
biting and crunching it i don't know
anything about that i can say just by
holding this there's no way these are
crispy
[Music]
well it's not that spicy that's kind of
spicy i do like this a lot
okay stop heating up
ooh that's catching up with me
slow burn slow builds on the heat so
here we've got japanese exclusive drinks
this one right here
is
water right
but it comes with
this assam tea pack
it's supposed to be hot but
it's cold and next one we've got coffee
this one right here is roasted rich
coffee
it's a little bit better than that
normal coffee and here we got
all gray iced tea it's not sweet at all
and next one is melon soda it has bright
green color
horrible it's too sweet here is ginger
ale nothing special and the last one is
nacho refreshing orange fountain drinks
there's a few that we can get that you
guys cannot over there in japan the
first one is a beverage that i have yet
to make one human being who enjoys it
of course i'm talking about sierra mist
maybe grossest soda ever
oh it's so bad another drink that you
can get at kfc that you can't get at
japan and here it is right here mountain
is great when i was in college i worked
at a pizza place i drink so much
mountain dew i threw up and now i'm
drinking mountain dew let's see if i can
do it again my favorite beverage
mountain dew sweet lightning
so good so good the drinks are just
normal nothing special but chickens
are
finger licking good
dessert to the uskfc you can get this
chocolate chip cookie recognize that guy
just looks just like this guy and
finally a chocolate chip cake
so let's talk about christmas in japan
so christmas is one of the biggest
events in japan even though about one
percent of japanese people are
christians we just enjoy christmas as
just a fun event and as for kfc for
christmas in japan back in
1970s japan kfc launched a hugely
successful advertising campaign called
kentucky new christmas that's kentucky
for christmas and with that strong
marketing campaign it became so popular
to have kfc for christmas in japan
and now about 3.6 million japanese
families eat kfc for christmas and
talking about my personal experiences
yes when i was young i would eat kfc for
christmas with my family but when you
start dating you know christmas makes
the transformation from a family event
to couples event and i'm looking for the
one who can enter kfc for christmas with
me
so in japan one drum stick of
so in japan one drum stick of original
chicken on average has 237 calories
chicken's looking a little limp there
george in the u.s one stiff drumstick of
original recipe is 130 calories but
according to kfc's us site that's for a
53 gram piece now adjusting for the 87
gram piece like that of japan the
calories go up to 210 does that make
sense great now take this bad boy and
make them extra crispy you got 270
calories so japan are two pieces of
original chickens and a small fry and a
medium drink is roughly
717 calories
a u.s two-piece individual fry and
medium drink comes out to be 990
calories so a lot more it's too many
calories
[Music]
not enough calories if you ask me but
finger licking good i think kfc got to
george he keeps dropping that slogan are
they paying george i think i think
george is getting some money on the side
from kfc oh my god if the george turns
out to be colonel sanders i'll lose my
mind
so kfc in japan doesn't disclose their
ingredients so we emailed their customer
support and this is what they told us
in the u.s our original recipe chicken
ingredients are first with the fresh
chicken it is marinated with salt sodium
phosphate and monosodium glutamate onto
the breading it's breaded with wheat
flour like calcium phosphate
maltodextrin triglycerides natural
flavor kernels secret original recipe
seasoning they also said our fries are
made of potatoes obviously and vegetable
oil and butt the butter is made of rice
flour vegetables starch and dextrose and
our fries which contain sea salt
monosodium glutamate try calcium
phosphate hydrolyzed soy protein
potassium chloride potatoes salt that's
good d germs yellow cornmeal sodium
dihydrogen pyrophosphate to maintain
natural color what's more natural than
disodium diohydrin pyrophosphates rolls
up the tongue and one thing i have to
say is that our fries are imported from
both america and belgium and some of the
belgium fries are made with potatoes
from france so our fries are truly truly
french
bonjour
in the u.s we have four chicken shapes
in japan we have five chicken shapes let
me explain so we have
this one it's called kale kale is like
chicken's breath
right here
i'm gonna say chicken's chest
[Music]
kill is like
chicken's chest right there first one is
the breast this is the big piece of
chicken your dad gets and also we got
wing it's a as you know chicken wing
this is supposed to be a wing this is
laughably small and we got this one it's
called rib chickens have ribs so rib is
like
under the chest
right here and we got this one thai
thigh is like chicken's lower back
and the next piece is this which i think
is the thigh and of course
the next piece everyone knows the drum
and this is a chicken's leg
hey if you enjoyed watching this episode
of us vs japan kfc we actually have
another series comparing the us and the
uk and you can watch that kfc episode
right here